la visite d'État qui avait lieu hier
bon chers collègues bonjour
désolé de ne pas avoir présidé la
première partie mais je rentrais Dardar
des Pays-Bas la visite des TACs qui
avait lieu hier
dîner royal tenue
[Musique]
voilà mais je tenais à être parmi vous
demain après-midi je rappelle que nous
avons dans le 13 pardon le 13 jeudi
c'est demain matin le jeudi 13 il faut
que j'ai les yeux on fasse des trous
9h30 audition de Madame Hélène tréeux du
chêne ambassadrice de France au
Royaume-Uni on la recevra en commun avec
la commission des affaires européennes
et initialement c'était en
c'était en visio et elle a accepté de
venir de Londres donc essayons de faire
des efforts pour
être présent
alors je vous rappelle donc que nous
allons procéder mais je dois vous tenir
quelques propos liminaires avant son
entrée nous allons procéder à l'audition
de Monsieur Gilles Andréani qui est le
candidat proposé par le Président de la
République pour
occuper les fonctions de président de la
commission du secret de la défense
nationale donc je vais vous rappeler les
dispositions législatives car je me dois
de le faire puis le candidat va entrer
dans la salle le président en
l'occurrence moi-même je lui souhaitais
la bienvenue je vais passer la parole
rapporteur
et puis après on va passer aux
opérations de vote et de dépouillement
ce dernier dépouillement devenant être
effectué simultanément avec l'Assemblée
nationale ça a lieu à quelle heure
assez à l'issue puisque elles sont bien
alors donc ce second point l'ordre du
jour appelle donc cette audition
je dois procéder à deux formalités le
rappel du cadre juridique et la
désignation d'un rapporteur s'agissant
du cas du juridique je rappelle qu'en
application du cinquième alinéa de
l'article 13 de la Constitution cette
nomination ne peut l'intervenir qu'après
l'audition du candidat devant les
commissions compétentes de l'Assemblée
nationale du Sénat ces auditions doivent
être suivies d'un vote les modalités de
cette audition et du vote ont été
précisées par la loi organique du 23
juillet 2010 et la loi ordinaire de la
même date l'audition doit être publique
et fait l'objet d'une captation
audiovisuelle en outre nous l'avons
ouvert à la presse il y a pas de presse
c'était ouvert portes sont ouvertes à
l'issue de cette audition nous
procéderons au vote qui se déroulera à
bulletin secret comme le prévoit
l'article 19 bis de notre règlement en
application de la loi du 23 juillet 2010
il ne peut y avoir de délégations de
vote et nous procéderons ensuite au
dépouillement je dois vous rappeler que
l'article 13 de la Constitution dispose
que le Président de la République ne
pourrait procéder à cette nomination si
l'addition des votes négatifs de chaque
commission représentait au moins 3/5 des
suffrages exprimés dans les deux
commissions et donc à l'issue de
l'audition je demanderai aux personnes
extérieures à notre commission de bien
vouloir quitter la salle afin que nous
puissions procéder au vote enfin en
application du Règlement du Sénat dans
le cas de cette procédure de nomination
de l'article 13 la Constitution nous
devons désigner un rapporteur à qui il
reviendra de présenter le candidat et de
formuler des questions je vous propose
de nommer pour
ce rapport notre collègue Pascal Alizard
et ce qui
a demandé d'accord visualisa est à son
poste donc je vais maintenant inviter
monsieur Gilles Andréani à nous
rejoindre pour débuter l'audition
donc conformément au texte que dont je
viens de rappeler les différents
éléments je suis heureux monsieur le
président Gilles Andréani de vous
accueillir ici je rappelle que vous
étiez jusqu'à en février dernier
président de la 4e chambre de la Cour
des comptes et vous avez été choisi par
le Président de la République en
application d'article 13 de la
Constitution pour proposer votre
candidature au poste de président de la
commission du secret de la défense
nationale c'est le président s'est
audition qui va être suivi d'un vote va
vous permettre de nous faire part de vos
motivations pour présider une autorité
administrative indépendante qui
occupe nous en sommes ici bien conscient
à la Commission de la Défense qui occupe
un rôle central dans la préservation ou
la levée du secret de la défense
nationale ce sujet nous concerne au
premier chef dans les compétences de
notre commission mais aussi pour
certains d'entre nous au titre de la
délégation parlementaire au
renseignement
enfin avant de donner la parole au
rapporteur puisque c'est la procédure je
souhaite signaler une particularité de
la Commission du secrétaire de la
Défense nationale qui est d'être à la
croisée du judiciaire et du
parlementaire puisque outre son
président ici ai-je deux magistrats un
magistrat du Conseil d'État et un autre
de la Cour de cassation et deux
parlementaires un député et une
sénatrice c'est notre collègue Catherine
bellriti membre de la commission des
lois je vous rappelle que cette audition
est ouverte à la presse
qui vont arriver et qu'elle fait l'objet
d'une captation vidéo retransmise
intégralement sur le site internet du
Sénat encore une fois bienvenue
président et je passe la parole au
rapporteur qui vient d'être désigné
notre collègue vice-président Pascal
Alizard monsieur le rapporteur vous avez
la parole
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président Andréani comme vient de le
rappeler le président Cambon vous avez
été jusqu'en février dernier président
de la quatrième chambre de la Cour des
comptes en charge du contrôle des
ministères de l'intérieur de la justice
des Affaires étrangères et des armées
ainsi que des services du Premier
ministre et de la présidente de la
République depuis votre nomination à la
Cour des comptes à votre sortie de l'ENA
en 1981 votre carrière s'est construite
en alternance entre vos fonctions de
magistrats et celles d'experts en
relation internationale au ministère des
Affaires étrangères et à l'OTAN vous
avez dirigé le Centre d'analyse et de
prévision et avait donc toujours été
concerné par les questions de défense et
de sécurité nationale vous êtes en
quelque sorte un praticien praticien
pardon du secret de la défense nationale
tantôt dans des fonctions exigeant le
secret pour préserver les intérêts
fondamentaux de la nation tantôt de
l'autre côté celui de l'exercice de la
justice et du contrôle votre qualité de
magistrat semble tout particulièrement
vous destiné à cette commission du
secret de la défense nationale monsieur
le Président c'est en fait à vous de
nous en convaincre et de nous expliquer
en quoi cette autorité indépendante
créée en 1998 a constitué une innovation
dans la déclassification et la
communication par le gouvernement
d'informations utiles à la justice par
définition le secret est dérogatoire à
nos principes de transparence de
contrôle et de libre accès des citoyens
aux informations la Commission du secret
de la défense nationale et donc au cœur
de cette exigence de conciliation entre
le fonctionnement de la justice et la
préservation de la sécurité nationale
depuis 2015 cette possibilité de
demander l'accès à des informations
classifiées a été étendu au Parlement
par la voie du président d'une des
commissions permanentes chargées des
affaires de Sécurité intérieure de la
défense ou des finances il s'agissait
ainsi d'une avance majeure pour le parle
d'une avancée majeure pour le Parlement
mais pourtant sur les 106 saisies
n'enregistrés par la commission entre
2016 et 2021 aucune n'a été formulée par
le Parlement quelle réflexion
pourriez-vous faire sur ce constat et
quel sujétion pourriez-vous nous faire
pour amorcer la pompe si vous me
permettez cette expression
alors que nous allons bientôt aborder
l'examen de la loi de programmation
militaire vos réflexions sur
d'éventuelles évolutions du dispositif
législatif actuel pourront aussi nous
être utiles j'observe que depuis 2009 le
président de la commission dispose d'un
pouvoir de perquisition
la Commission du secret de la défense
nationale dispose d'un pouvoir de
perquisition dans le but de prévenir le
risque de compromission d'information
protégée de 2009 à 2021 72 perquisitions
ont été réalisées
disposez-vous des moyens juridiques et
en ressources humaines suffisante pour
cette mission notamment pour examiner
des données numériques et enfin à la
lecture du dernier rapport de la
Commission du secret défense nationale
pour la période 2019 et 2021 on peut
déplorer l'allongement continu des
délais moyens de traitement entre la
date de saisine de l'autorité
administrative par la juridiction et la
date de saisine de la CSDN par
l'autorité administrative ce délai de
transmission qui était en moyenne de 44
jours sur la période
99-2009 est passé à 188 jours sur le
trienna 2019 2021 il faut noter que les
deux plus mauvais élèves entre
guillemets sont le ministère de
l'intérieur avec un délai moyen de 291
jours et le ministère des armées avec un
délai moyen de 164 jours par comparaison
le ministère des Affaires étrangères
ainsi que les services du Premier
ministre effectuent cette transmission
en 5 à 6 jours le delta est quand même
extrêmement important comment expliquer
ces délais de traitement et quelle
réforme mettre en oeuvre pour résorber
ce point noir du dispositif de
déclassification monsieur le Président
j'en ai fini pour ma part et je vous
remercie monsieur le président André
Annie des réponses que vous pourrez nous
faire
merci Monsieur rapporteur merci Pascal
sur le Président je vous laisse la
parole
merci monsieur le Président merci de
votre de votre accueil et merci à
monsieur le rapporteur
des observations qu'il vient de formuler
c'est pour moi un honneur d'être
aujourd'hui présent
à cette audition qui a pour objectif
d'examiner la nomination envisagée à la
tête de la Commission du secret de la
défense nationale et de la soumettre à
vos suffrages je commencerai si vous le
voulez bien par quelques mots sur la
Commission et son rôle ensuite sur mon
parcours et les intentions qui sont les
miennes si cette nomination est
confirmée va à son terme et enfin je
répondrai aux trois questions monsieur
le rapporteur que vous avez soulevé
nos collègues après évidemment
sur le premier point
vous l'avez rappelé vous-même monsieur
le rapporteur tous les pays
démocratiques reconnaissent la nécessité
de protéger le secret de la défense
nationale à l'aide de dispositions
particulières qui dérochent largement
aux droits communs de l'accès aux
documents
administratifs et surtout de l'accès à
ces documents par les autorités
judiciaires ou le Parlement
saisi par voie de
QPC des dispositions du Code de la
défense qui régissent ce secret le
Conseil constitutionnel les avait l'idée
en 2011 par une décision
de 1192 et estimé je cite que le secret
de la défense nationale participe de la
sauvegarde des intérêts fondamentaux de
la nation
or la protection du secret de la défense
nationale un combat en France comme
ailleurs principalement à l'exécutif
dans le cadre d'un régime légal et pénal
qui fait largement échappé
celui-ci au mécanisme de contrôle
juridictionnel et parlementaire de droit
commun il possède une large part
d'appréciation pour décider quels sont
les informations qui doivent être
protégées par le secret de la défense
nationale et quand doit cesser cette
protection les décisions qu'il prend à
cet effet ne sont pas soumises au
contrôle du juge une fois protégé les
informations relevant du secret de la
défense nationale ne sont normalement
pas excessives accessible qu'à des
personnes habilitées et ils peuvent être
produites dans une procédure
juridictionnelle à la différence des
autres secrets protégés par la loi leur
communication au Parlement est elle
aussi limitée
ces exceptions que justifie les
exigences de la sauvegarde des intérêts
fondamentaux de la Nation pour reprendre
les mots du Conseil constitutionnel
doivent cependant être conciliés dit le
conseil dans la même décision avec le
droit des personnes à un recours
juridictionnel effectif et un procès
équitable et avec la recherche des
auteurs d'infraction il faut ajouter à
ces exigences celles qui touche au
pouvoir de contrôle du Parlement
pour effectuer une conciliation
équilibrée entre ces deux séries
d'objectifs notre pays a choisi un
dispositif original la création d'une
autorité indépendante la Commission du
secret de la défense nationale chargé
d'examiner les documents classifiés dont
la production serait réclamée à
l'exécutif par un juge ou depuis 2015
par le Parlement et de rendre un avis
public sur cette déclassification
la Commission est saisi à cette fin par
l'autorité administrative à laquelle le
juge ou le président d'une des
commissions désignées par la loi
adresse ça demande la commission rend
son avis dans les deux mois et cet avis
publié au Journal officiel la Commission
a d'ailleurs toujours respectée ce
délestatuant en moyenne dans les 20 à 30
jours après qu'elle ait été saisie
le législateur réveillé à ce que la
Commission du secret soit indépendante
par sa composition que vous avez rappelé
de parlementaires nommé par les
présidents de l'Assemblée nationale et
du Sénat de ce qu'elle a faim de leur
mandat et trois magistrats nommés pour 6
ans non renouvelable selon la procédure
de l'article 13 de la Constitution
l'examen de leur nomination par les
commissions compétentes de l'Assemblée
nationale et du Sénat confortant
l'autorité et l'indépendance de la
Commission
ce dispositif est original et équilibrée
il est né dans un contexte particulier
qui était un contexte judiciaire où
l'opposition du secret de la défense
nationale au juge dans des affaires à
l'époque très sensible
avait pu laisser croire que cette
classification avait pour objet de
soustraire certains éléments de ses
affaires au contrôle du juge
plutôt qu'a préserver le secret de la
défense nationale c'est dans ce contexte
que la Commission a été créée
j'estime que le dispositif trouvé est à
la fois original je l'ai dit il n'a pas
d'équivalent dans d'autres pays il est
équilibré il charge la commission de
balancer les exigences du secret avec
celle de la bonne administration de la
justice et de l'exercice de la mission
de contrôle du Parlement
le fait que ces avis soient publics en
fait un tiers de confiance qui atteste
que si un document est protégé c'est
bien pour des raisons d'intérêt national
et non pour d'autres motifs en même
temps ce dispositif respecte la
séparation des pouvoirs qui voient
l'exécutif décider à la fin de la
procédure de la déclassification mais au
vu d'un avis indépendant public qui de
faite tempèrent le pouvoir
discrétionnaire qui le sien en ce
domaine comme le prouve le fait que dans
la quasi-totalité des cas le ministre
concerné suit la vie de la Commission
son existence a d'ailleurs été prise en
compte par le Conseil constitutionnel
dont les décisions que je viens de citer
pour déclarer à une disposition près il
est vrai le régime légal du secret de la
défense nationale conforme à la
Constitution
le bilan de la Commission à ce jour
apparaît très largement positif
il est saisi jusqu'à présent dans le
disons pour simplifier dans la totalité
des cas par l'autorité judiciaire ou par
un tribunal administratif dans la
proportion disons de
trois quarts un quart
au plus précisément il est saisi par les
autorités administratives auxquelles
s'adresse le juge
et ses avis ont été réclamés dans la
très grande majorité des cas 60% par le
ministre des Armées 30% par le ministre
de l'Intérieur
la Commission a rendu des avis
favorables à la déclassification totale
ou partielle dans les trois quarts des
cas dont elle était saisie et a émis un
avis défavorable à la déclassification
à peu près dans la proportion d'un quart
depuis
l'origine
les avis étant suivi par l'exécutif dans
95% des cas 100% au cours des 6 années
correspondant au mandat de Jean-Pierre
Bel qui a présidé avec autorité
efficacité cette commission pendant les
six ans qui viennent de de s'écouler
s'agissant des pouvoirs de
demande de déclassification du Parlement
en fait le traitement de la première
demande de ce type est en cours elle a
été effectuée à la demande du président
de la commission des lois de l'Assemblée
nationale pour les besoins de la
Commission sur la souveraineté
commissions d'enquête sur la
souveraineté et
énergétique de la nation et l'avis de la
commission sera je crois rendu dans les
tous prochains jours sur cette sur cette
demande donc on a la première exemple de
ces signes de saisine parlementaires
en ce qui me concerne
je suis évidemment honoré d'avoir été
pressenti et désigné
sous réserve de vos suffrages pour
présider cette institution
dont le bilan me paraît
important
je m'efforcerai si ma nomination va à
son terme de faire en sorte qu'elle
exerce pleinement sa mission
dans des conditions d'indépendance
d'un partialité et d'efficacité
sur lesquelles je reviendrai dans dans
un instant pour parler un tout petit peu
de de mon parcours professionnel
en effet vous avez bien voulu le rapport
rappeler monsieur le rapporteur je vais
passer à peu près la moitié de ma
carrière un peu moins de la moitié de ma
carrière en détachement au ministère de
la Défense brièvement et plus longuement
au ministère des Affaires étrangères je
suis beaucoup occupé de questions de
sécurité internationale
j'ai ensuite présidé la quatrième
chambre de la Cour des comptes qui outre
les ministères que vous avez mentionnés
ou plutôt au titre des ministères que
vous avez mentionnés monsieur le
rapporteur
veille au contrôle des services de
renseignement et donc assez divertitres
j'ai tout au long de ma carrière eu à
connaître d'informations classifiées et
à travailler avec les administrations
responsables de leur de leurs production
donc je crois connaître les exigences du
de la protection du secret de la défense
nationale et les contraintes qui s'y
attachent cependant j'appartiens par
formation et pour y avoir passé l'autre
moitié de ma carrière à une institution
la Cour des comptes dont le mission est
de contrôler les administrations
d'informer les citoyens et d'éclairer le
débat public et la transparence est en
quelque sorte dans l'ADN de la Cour des
comptes
et au fond entre ces deux séries
d'exigences que j'ai eu à confronter
dans ma carrière et celle que la loi
charge
la CSDN d'équilibrer
prendre en compte d'une part les
exigences de la protection des intérêts
fondamentaux de la nation dit
l'article du Code de la défense qui qui
décrit les critères qui doivent présider
aux décisions de la commission et
d'autre part les exigences de la bonne
administration de la justice et des
droits de la défense et auquel la loi
ajoutée en 2015 le pouvoir de contrôle
du Parlement il y a au fond entre ces
deux séries de critères un équilibre à
trouver qui ressemble je dirais aux deux
pôles de mon activité de mon activité
professionnelle
j'ajoute que sur la méthode la
commission sans être une juridiction
si apparence par son sa composition
trois magistrats de parlementaires et
son mode de décision autant dire que
l'indépendance la collégialité
l'impartialité le respect pour le
service public de la justice sont des
principes que je me suis à mon niveau et
forcément
œuvre à la Cour des comptes et que je
m'efforcerai également de faire présider
aux travaux de la commission
vous avez monsieur le rapporteur évoqué
la question préoccupante du délai de
saisine de la commission par l'autorité
administrative à laquelle s'adresse soit
le juge soit le Parlement la dégradation
que vous avez mentionnée est
préoccupante et si je peux par avance
m'a signé un objectif prioritaire ce
sera de réduire de réduire ce délai qui
est tout à fait anormal qui tient qui
tient je dirais
disons à deux séries de facteurs
les premiers que l'on ne peut partager
qui
tiennent simplement à je dirais
l'inertie administrative et une forme de
négligence qui
se manifeste en particulier quand le
juge ou le Parlement demande des
documents précisément désignés et
identifier alors aucune raison pour
qu'on mette du temps à produire ces
documents à la Commission à saisir
celle-ci comme ça arrive trop souvent
l'autre cas de figure et celui dans
lequel le juge demande à
une autorité administrative responsable
de la classification initiale des
données l'ensemble des documents se
rapportant à une affaire et parfois
cette demande concerne plusieurs
services on peut imaginer qu'il faille
un peu de temps pour les rassembler mais
de là à mettre je dirais des
périodes de temps qui peuvent dépasser
les 100 jours 140 180 c'est retombées
cette année monsieur le rapporteur à 140
mais c'est beaucoup trop d'autant
qu'initialement la Commission a été
saisie dans un délai qui ne dépassait
pas 60 jours donc il y a une dégradation
à laquelle il faut véritablement
s'attacher
je pense qu'une des méthodes possibles
seraient de faire en sorte mais ça sauf
bonne pratique réellement partagée et
appliquées par les administrations ça
demande une modification de la loi ce
serait que la Commission soit avisée de
la demande
du juge ou
de la saisine parlementaire de façon
formelle en même temps qu'en effet si
l'autorité administrative de façon à
pouvoir se mettre en relation avec
celle-ci et lui demander de s'expliquer
au cas où le délai serait trop important
ou tout simplement d'inscrire dans la
loi et délai un délai obligatoire qui
permettent de régler cette question en
tout cas c'est une question que
dont mon prédécesseur encore une fois
sous réserve de la
le suffrage qui sera le vôtre
il était bien sensible à cette question
et c'est un des sujets qu'il faut
s'efforcer de régler alors il avait été
mis un tout petit peu entre parenthèses
à la suite de la crise du covid qui
pouvait expliquer un tout petit peu
l'allongement des délais
particulièrement important de 2020 2021
mais une seule justifie vraiment plus et
donc il y a lieu de si de s'y attachés
donc ce sera je crois un travail
prioritaire à prioritaire à
entreprendre
encore une fois peut-être la
passera-t-il par une
par une modification de la loi faute que
s'il est bonne pratique auxquelles on
peut songer ne sont pas suivis en ce qui
concerne la saisine parlementaire
monsieur le rapporteur
la commission est à la disposition
des autorités qui auxquelles
s'adresseraient les demandes
parlementaires il y a les trois
présidents de commission de chaque
chacune des assemblées sont disposés à
cet égard d'un très large pouvoir la
seule réserve et qui doivent motiver
leur demande puisque comme les comme les
juridictions cette obligation de
motivation qui part parenthèse facilite
beaucoup le travail de la commission
s'impose s'impose s'impose à eux
j'allais dire la commission
directement à la disposition du
Parlement pour pour toutes ces îles
qu'elle
que les présidents de ces commissions
souhaiteraient souhaiteraient effectuer
et comme cela a été le cas de la part de
l'Assemblée nationale elle appuie de
commission d'enquête ça peut ça peut se
ça peut se ça peut s'envisager en toute
état de cause
il me semble parlant de façon
personnelle que c'est un progrès
important que la loi de 2015 est ouvert
cette faculté ou Parlement et par
conséquent il lui appartient de il lui
appartient de de l'utiliser sur les
délais je crois monsieur le rapporteur
avoir répondu à votre question en ce qui
concerne les perquisitions
depuis 2009 et ça fait suite à la
décision du Conseil constitutionnel qui
a invalidé une disposition un peu
restrictive à cet égard du Code de la
défense dans la décision que je viens de
citer
lorsqu'une perquisition se déroule
dans ce qu'on appelle la locale abrite
temps c'est un local répertorié comme
contenant des documents relevant du
secret de la défense nationale
le juge adresse une une demande motivée
qui permet de mettre
sa perquisition en rapport avec l'objet
de son instruction et le président de la
commission assiste à la perquisition les
documents classifiés ne sont pas saisis
par le juge mais remis au président de
la commission qui en quelque sorte les
sélectionne au fur et à mesure que se
déroule la procédure et la Commission en
essayant de dans les limites de temps
qui sont les siennes de sélectionner les
documents se rapportant
je dirais aux motifs qui ont justifié la
perquisition ces documents sont ensuite
confié à la garde du président de la
commission et examiné par la commission
dans le même je dirais sur la même
procédure qu'elle examine les autres
documents et elle émet un avis sur
l'opportunité l'opportunité au regard
des critères que la loi lui assigne de
déclassifier ses documents donc c'est
cela la procédure et les doubler d'une
autre procédure qui est que si
fortuitement à l'occasion d'une
perquisition dans un lieu privé par
exemple dans un domicile des documents
relevant du secret de la défense
nationale sont découverts à ce moment-là
le président de la commission où sont
délégués se rend sans délais sur les
lieux pour procéder au même au même tri
s'il s'agit de supports numériques
la Commission fait appel à toute expert
pour ensuite
procéder je dirais à la mise à jour des
informations saisies sur support
numérique et se saisir ensuite de la
question selon ses procédures
habituelles c'est une procédure à qui au
début était un petit peu compliqué à
régler avec avec les juges fallait par
quels instruction puisqu'en gros il y a
très peu de il y a peu de père qui il y
a pas de perquisition autre que
judiciaire
et finalement cette procédure est à
présent à présent convenablement
convenablement réglé et je comprends
de l'avoir pratiqué qu'elle s'exerce
dans des conditions dans des conditions
satisfaisantes
pour conclure
il me semble que le dispositif que j'ai
décrit
respecte
respect comme je l'ai dit là séparation
des pouvoirs
le la fonction de président de la
Commission
d'un organisme collégial n'applique pas
je dirais de chercher à imprimer sa
marque à une institution qui doit
sonorer de ce caractère collégial et et
collectif
mais j'aborde la fonction pour laquelle
le président de la République a envisagé
ma nomination en ayant conscience du
rôle important et original qui est celui
qui est le sien
autorité administrative elle est à la
jonction comme vous l'avez dit du
législatif et du judiciaire
par la destination des documents sur
lesquels rend un avis et par sa
composition
son indépendance essentielle à
l'accomplissement de sa mission et
confortée par le mode de désignation de
ses membres et
comme je l'ai déjà dit par son mode de
fonctionnement collégial et au total
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs je serai fier de
représenter et de faire progresser si je
peux
cet organe important et au rôle
peut-être insuffisamment reconnu de
notre État de droit je vous remercie
merci monsieur le Président pour cette
présentation présentation personnelle
mais aussi description d'un organisme
moins connu de nos collègues alors même
qu'ils jouent un rôle important et puis
nous avoir fait part de vos de vos
intentions à la fois sur
l'accélération du
rythme des décisions car c'est un sujet
plus général auquel la Commission est
confrontée notamment en matière
d'approbation des traités qui viennent
parfois des années des années plus tard
ce qui rend quand même et alors même que
les traités sont des gens en activité
toujours assez curieux et puis bien sûr
tout ce qui relève secret de la défense
nationale vous avez raison de rappeler
les pouvoirs du président de commission
je
pourrais presque même regretter à la
faveur d'un souvenir qui que je
rappellerai un certain qui nous avait
simplement conduit à convoquer la
ministre de la Défense dans une
formation restreinte du bureau mais où
nous aurions peut-être aimé avoir le le
concours
la commission pour éclairer un sujet
d'actualité défense qui nous
interpellait à l'époque je ne souhaite
pas en dire plus mais mes collègues
savent très bien à quoi je fais allusion
alors sans plus attendre j'ai deux
intervenants Yannick Yannick vognard qui
appartient du reste aussi à la DPR et
qui préside cette commission de
surveillance des techniques de
communication et où il fait du reste un
travail absolument extraordinaire une
nouvelle fois lui rendre hommage ici et
donc je lui donne la parole puis après
Ludovic est merci beaucoup président
merci de vos propos monsieur André ni
vous l'avez souligné il s'agit là de
sujets extrêmement sensible de la
sauvegarde des intérêts fondamentaux de
la nation
et parallèlement il s'agit aussi d'être
extrêmement sourcilieux vigilant
s'agissant d'une part des pouvoirs de
contrôle du Parlement ou lorsque c'est
nécessaire de ne pas soustraire quoi que
ce soit au contrôle du si ce n'est pas
nécessaire si ce n'est pas indispensable
donc vous avez souligné que vous
exerceriez pleinement votre mission en
s'appuyant notamment sur sa volonté
d'indépendance et c'est sur cette
question que je veux vous interroger sur
sur deux aspects qui sont qui ont pu
être importants en qualité de président
donc de la quatrième chambre de la Cour
des comptes vomit sur le contrôle donc
vous ont déjà conduit du reste à
connaître des informations classifiées
donc de grande importance c'est le cas
également de la délégation parlementaire
au renseignement ce siège avec notre
président Christian Cambon dans ses
missions d'information et de contrôle
aussi je me permets de vous interroger
sur des cas où le gouvernement a pu
s'opposer à communiquer des informations
c'est en entrant dans le détail mais le
diable parfois peut être dans les
détails on peut se rendre compte
véritablement de la mission qu'il a
vôtre et des décisions susceptibles que
vous seriez amené à prendre je pense aux
prétendus bombardement attribué à la
France au Bounty au Mali voilà faire
Pegasus pensez-vous qu'un de ces cas
aurait pu faire l'objet d'une demande de
lever de secret auprès de la commission
de secret de la défense nationale que
vous pourriez avoir l'honneur de
présider merci
merci Yannick Ludovic
merci monsieur le Président merci
mesdames et messieurs de votre présence
chers collègues permettez-moi tout
d'abord de saluer le travail de
l'ensemble de la commission des affaires
étrangères à la défense à travers
notamment le travail de notre rapporteur
et qui a permis notamment de bien fixer
les attentes de notre commission et plus
généralement du Sénat vis-à-vis de la
commission à laquelle vous vous postulez
monsieur Andréani permettez-moi
également de vous remercier de votre
présence j'aurai une question qui serait
relativement courte il ne vous a pas
échappé que nous opérons actuellement un
virage technologique
très important avec l'émergence de
nombreuses technologies plus ou moins
bien maîtrisées comment envisagez-vous
l'adaptation de cette commission à la
protection du secret défense donc à
l'ère du numérique avec une accélération
phénoménale des transferts de
l'information du développement
incontestable et des actions de cyber
malveillance de l'émergence indubitable
de la désinformation couplée au
développement de l'intelligence
artificielle
et quid de votre vision quant à la
fiabilité humaine quelques heures
seulement après la divulgation par le
Pentagone de fuite de documents classés
top secret qui met en danger les forces
militaires engagées dans le conflit
russo-ukrainien je vous remercie
merci Monsieur président
ma question se porte concernant la vie
du Conseil d'État intervenu en juillet
2021 sur les délais d'accès aux archives
de plus de 50 ans j'aimerais connaître
votre avis sur cette décision merci
merci alors
venant s'inscrive xori merci président
monsieur le Président je suis pas
certain d'avoir bien compris est-ce que
vous pouvez nous expliquer quels sont
les critères qui forgent la vie de la
Commission sur une demande de
déclassification d'information classée
secret défense quels sont alors les
éléments ou informations qui seraient
jugés comme relevant impérativement du
secret défense en
clair et en schématisant y a-t-il une
marge d'appréciation en fonction de la
composition de la commission je vous
remercie
merci Hugues Joël guerriot
oui merci président très rapidement
comment vous le pensez-vous que la
Commission pourrait élargir ses
compétences en particulier en terme de
force de proposition ou d'auto saisie
jusqu'aujourd'hui elle n'est pas dans
cette voie là
voilà j'ai passé 10 autres demandes
d'intervention c'est le Président je
vous laisse la parole pour répondre à
ces intervenants
merci monsieur le Président
bon l'indépendant c'est les
fondamentales à l'exercice de la
de la mission de la de la commission je
crois qu'elle est pleinement garantie
par son statut et ça
et sa composition dans le cadre de
l'exercice des missions de contrôle qui
ont été les miennes à la tête de la
quatrième chambre
que puis-je dire oui il y a des
administrations qui d'ailleurs
secret de la défense nationale ou non
exprime des réticents pour pas dire plus
à communiquer les informations
il y a une tendance
qui n'est pas tout à fait dissipée au
sein de
nombreuses administrations
à opposé de l'inertier parfois des de
francs refus à des demandes pourtant
parfaitement légitimes et en plus
confortée par la loi de la Cour des
comptes j'ai été confronté à ce type de
de situation je dis non je n'ai jamais
cédé
je me suis toujours efforcé de
convaincre nos interlocuteurs ce qui est
exact d'ailleurs que les secrets
protégés par la loi ne sont pas
opposables à la Cour des comptes et que
il lui appartient en revanche de
les protéger elle-même et de ne pas en
faire une taille une fois qu'elles sont
les servies pour se forger l'opinion
dont elle fait ensuite mention dans ses
rapports elle doit le faire d'une façon
telle que les secrets ne soient pas
compromis sauf à classifier ce que nous
pouvons faire les rapports les plus les
plus sensibles c'est une discipline à
laquelle je me suis toujours efforcé et
que bien entendu avec
je ne
non seulement je n'en
diminuerai pas mes exigences à cet égard
mais il est clair qu'elles sont
inhérentes aux fonctions auxquelles
auquel
j'aspire devant vous
[Musique]
en ce qui concerne les bons je peux pas
me prononcer pas et vivre comprend bien
je peux pas me prononcer sur des
affaires particulières en plus dont je
n'ai vend que par par la presse je ne
j'ai aucune connaissance de l'intérieur
de la commission sinon pour dire quand
même qu'elle a cet égard elle s'est
forgée je comprends
une jurisprudence une pratique qu'on
discerne dans les avis
les avis qu'elle
rend publique
qui me donne la pensée qu'elle
je dirais que ces exigences de
transparence sont tout à fait
tout à fait essentiel dans
l'accomplissement dans l'accomplissement
de sa de sa mission et que
l'instinct ou l'attitude pour ce que je
peux en comprendre des administrations
qui
la saisissent
sont plutôt que et c'est bien l'objectif
de la loi que la charge de la preuve
vis-à-vis de la commission leur incombe
qu'elle doivent convaincre la commission
que les tel ou tel document ne doit pas
être divulgué pour des raisons
impérieuses qu'elle doit expliquer à la
commission il me paraît donc il y a une
là une disons une discipline qui s'est
forgée qui rend
j'ose le croire mais je ne le sais pas
encore de l'Intérieur qui rend
praticable vis-à-vis de la commission
des stratégies de d'obstruction ou de
refus d'accès plus récents ça me paraît
pas pensable si vous voulez contenu de
la longue pratique de la de la
commission
pour ce qui concerne le virage numérique
c'est évidemment un sujet lourd pour
pour la commission
parfois les saisies
aboutissent à
je comprends je ne encore une fois que
j'ai pas de témoignage interne direct à
vous à partager avec vous mais
à mettre disons à la disposition de la
commission peut-être par parce qu'on
peut pas faire le tri d'un support
numérique instantanément des masses
d'information très importantes ensuite
dont elle doit ensuite extraire celle
qui sont pertinentes du point de vue de
du point de vue de l'instruction en pour
le cas où le cas échéant de la
oui venant vis-à-vis de l'instruction en
cours donc mais pour cela d'après ce que
je comprends les les services de l'État
compétent auprès de leurs concours à la
Commission et elle n'a jamais jusqu'ici
reconnu disons eu aucune difficulté
technique à
surmonter ce problème jusqu'à présent
sous réserve de comme vous le mentionnez
monsieur le sénateur de l'évolution
technologique alors pour ce qui concerne
madame sénatrice les l'accès aux
documents de plus de 50 ans
je dirais de choses c'est par principe
une bonne chose que les historiens
puissent
avoir accès aux documents
frappés du secret va du Saut du secret
de la défense nationale après 50 ans ou
plus précisément
qu'il y ait une présomption selon la vie
du Conseil d'État que ces documents
doivent être déclassifiés sachant que
certains peuvent encore l'être après 50
ans et dans ce cas là la Commission
peut indirectement en connaître à
travers les contentieux qui pourraient
naître de refus de communication à ce
titre et donc je crois qu'il y a un ou
deux cas dans lequel la Commission a eu
à
se prononcer
il n'est pas ce n'est pas une vue de
l'esprit qu'un secret de la défense
nationale de plus de 50 ans mérite
encore d'être protégé
j'en citerai juste un exemple qui
m'avait frappé à l'époque c'est que les
les techniques d'enrichissement dans cet
été servis Saddam Hussein pour fabriquer
du
je crois que c'est l'uranium ou le
plutonium je ne sais plus l'uranium
enrichit de qualité militaire était
directement issue de documents des
classifiés du Projet Manhattan du projet
de bombes atomique américain la deuxième
guerre mondiale donc il y a certains
secrets qui méritent sans doute d'être
protégé au-delà de au-delà de
au-delà de 50 ans
élargir les pouvoirs de la Commission
je peux pas imaginer d'auto saisine je
vois pas comment la Commission pourrait
se saisir elle-même
mais la Commission pourrait peut-être
mais l'âge le hasard de une simple
hypothèse parce qu'encore une fois une
connaissons pas depuis l'intérieur c'est
ces modes de fonctionnement je ne peux
pas me prononcer sur ce point mais je
pourrais imaginer disons deux
de direction la première serait
peut-être que la
Commission soit un petit disons et son
avis comme vous le sujet monsieur le
sénateur en tout cas
son mot à dire sur les disons de la
politique à mon métier de
déclassification qu'on lui demande son
avis comme
disons si on doit revisiter
l'instruction générale interministériale
sur la protection du secret ou en
examiner telle ou tel modalité peut-être
la commission pourrait-elle avoir une
vue sur la question je ne je ne sais pas
on peut l'imaginer
peut-être sur des sujets là encore jeux
hasard juste cette idée mais je surtout
très élève je sais pas si c'est
praticable ou utile
mais qu'elle soit plus systématiquement
[Musique]
saisi autrement que par la voie de
contentieux éventuelle sur les
problématiques de déclassification de
documents historiques peut-être un tel
un rôle possible à jouer dans ce domaine
il me semble pour autant que dans les
temps actuels de la loi
sa mission est claire
elle cette combinaison d'avis qui laisse
la faculté mais dont il utilise très peu
dont il fait très peu usage à l'exécutif
de ne pas suivre la vie de la commission
me paraît au bout du compte un assez
bonne équilibre sa mission est bien
définie c'est pouvoir sont clairs le
pouvoir d'instruction
du président des services qu'il
assistent sont son
ou ouvre une une
disons des possibilités de dialogue et
de
d'interrogations des administrations sur
les motifs qui sont les leurs lorsqu'ils
demandent le maintien d'une
classification
attachée à un document tout ça me paraît
équilibré et je vois pas aujourd'hui de
de besoin mais peut-être changer d'avis
je ne sais pas
impérieux qui pourrait conduire à
élargir le champ d'action de la
Commission
d'avoir une petite question
complémentaire de notre collègue Olivier
sigoletti oui merci monsieur le
Président une petite question nous
sommes au sein de cette commission à
certains noms de rapporteurs budgétaires
être confronté depuis quelques années à
la classification de la DTO de la
disponibilité technique opérationnelle
ce qui nous pose quelques quelques
problèmes dans l'exercice de nos
missions de contrôle est-ce que vous
pensiez monsieur le Président qui ne
s'agit pas en l'occurrence d'un élément
de sur classification et qu'elles
peuvent être les marges d'appréciation à
la matière merci
merci pour cette question monsieur le
sénateur c'est une évolution qui nous a
frappé puisque les la disponibilités
étaient matérielles étaient aujourd'hui
dans les documents budgétaires exprimés
en rapport au contrat opérationnel et
non en valeur absolue comme c'était le
cas jusqu'à il y a encore deux ou trois
ans il semble-t-il
nous avons relevé le point dans un
rapport public thématique sur la mise en
oeuvre de la loi de programmation
immunitaire pour tout dire la Cour des
comptes sécurisé elle regrettait et à
dire que
en privé ainsi le Parlement d'une
information qui était importante et dont
on n'avait pas jugé jusqu'à présent
qu'elle fut contraires aux intérêts
supérieurs de la nation pour reprendre
le terme canonique donc je me suis
responsable de cette publication donc
j'assume ce point de vue en tant qu'
ancien président de la quatrième chambre
après
ça ne préjuge en rien de ce que sera la
décision de la Commission au cas où elle
elle serait saisie de ce sujet par
l'intermédiaire disons d'une saisine
parlementaire ça
veut dire ça je suis évidemment je
réserve totalement la position qui
pourrait être celle de la Commission à
cet égard mais le fait était le fait que
vous soulignez nous avez également
frappé
merci monsieur le Président je pense que
c'était échange aura eu le mérite
d'abord d'éclairer l'ensemble de nos
collègues sur le fonctionnement et
l'utilité la grande utilité d'une
commission que nous aurons tous intérêt
à peut-être saisir plus plus fréquemment
car
plus particulièrement notre commission
est véritablement soumise très souvent à
de grandes difficultés pour obtenir
communication d'éléments qui sont
absolument essentiels à nos prises de
décision et je lui dis d'autant plus que
nous allons aborder une loi de
programmation militaire dont les
prémices nous laissent à penser que elle
joue sur certains points dans le flou
qui n'est pas artistique mais qui est
peut-être voulu et si le Parlement doit
comme la Cour des comptes chacun dans
ses compétences de exercer un rôle de
contrôle c'est évidemment sur la base
d'éléments concrets donc je pense que
cet échange sera profil et sans préjugés
du vote des deux commissions je peux
formuler le souhait que si ces
commissions vous confirment nous
puissions à la fois
nous fonder sur la compétence que vous
avez acquise dans des plus hautes
responsabilités que vous avez exercées
et aussi sur cette volonté
d'indépendance car je crois qu'il faut
que des organismes de contrôle dans un
pays où l'exécutif
exerce ses compétences de manière
de manière assez sensible je pense que
il faut que des organismes de contrôle
puissent rappeler au gouvernement la
nécessité de se soumettre soit par la
voix administrative et juridique au
contrôle la Cour des comptes bien sûr
mais aussi à celle du Parlement qui
parfois des difficultés à exercer ses
propres missions je vous remercie
monsieur le Président merci merci
[Applaudissements]
dans quelques instants nous allons
procéder au vote
quelques instants de suspension